meu pai sempre dizia que a gente não
pode passar pela vida e como passam os
passarinhos
a gente tem que fazer mais que isso a
gente tem que deixar um legado
desde pequena eu sempre importar muito
com isso e fazer de ter uma carreira que
fizesse muito sentido pra mim e que eu
pudesse ajudar alguém com isso essa
pergunta sempre me incomodou muito o que
eu quero ser quando crescer em maio
quanto mais próximo e chegando
vestibular mas não chegava ficava porque
esse momento começava a chegar
essa escolha foi muito difícil para mim
porque eu vi a carreira de uma forma
muito estereotipada
eu achava que além da minha formação uma
carreira define os meus amigos
os locais que iria frequentar a roupa
que eu ia usar o meu o meu estilo de
vida então escolher uma profissão seria
como escolher uma cadeira com a sentar
não podia sentar em todas
eu tinha que escolher uma e sentar em
uma promessa eu investi muito tempo e
dinheiro em orientações vocacionais
mas elas me levaram a lugar nenhum
eu demorei sete anos para descobrir um
jeito muito mais fácil de fazer isso que
eu gostaria de compartilhar com vocês
hoje cinco dicas que eu aprendi nessa
jornada
eu comecei a aprender no final do ano
passado
eu descobri que o empreendedorismo tem
tudo a ver com a escolha de carreira
pra começar o endereço não era nada que
eu imaginava eu tinha um exemplo muito
forte na minha família meus pais foram
empreendedores e nem os negócios deles
deu certo então achava que
empreendedores não era uma boa ideia
nunca foi uma opção mas a descobrir
estudando que existem várias formas de
empreendedorismo o que meus pais faziam
era o empreendedorismo convencional
existem outras formas como impedir
empreendedorismo enxuto que é o que se
aplica nos estar tanto o convencional
o primeiro tem uma idéia genial e aí
tudo cria uma necessidade e joga no
mercado vai dar certo
quando você faz uma startup na verdade
teve uma oportunidade de ver um problema
você cria uma solução para esse problema
na verdade é convencional você pega a
ideia e começa a estruturar ela investir
muito tempo recursos contrata
funcionários para ir jogar no mercado e
ver se vai dar certo
uma startup primeiro você vê um problema
e uma oportunidade de resolver esse
problema através de um negócio no
entanto começa criando um negócio válida
ver se ele se ele resolve aquela solução
se dar certo
aí você implementa investe dinheiro e
tempo nisso
se não der certo o refino de ter um
modelo de negócio e testa de novo nisso
existem dois conceitos que são
fundamentais que é o mvp e o ato de pivô
para mvp é o mais é uma sigla em inglês
que significa mini o produto viável
nada mais é do que um teste onde você
investe o mínimo de tempo recurso para
ter o máximo de experiência possível do
seu cliente e o ato de votar é quando
não deu certo a idéia de negócio e do
refino de modelo de negócio muda algum
detalhe dele ou até mesmo ele inteiro
para que eles realmente resolva aquela
solução
quando olho para trás na minha carreira
quando comecei a escolher minha carreira
eu vejo que na verdade é exatamente o
empreendedorismo convencional disso
quando tinha 17 anos achava eu queria
ser médica
então eu comecei a estudar medicina
comecei a investir pocinho comecei a
estudar várias horas por dia para
conseguir passar no vestibular mas eu
esqueci me de testar realmente era
aquilo que eu queria fazer reverter isso
aconteceu na verdade meio que por acaso
no meu no ano de estudo meu pai acabou
se acidentando e eu tive que ficar no
hospital por um tempo mais longo do que
estava acostumada e eu pude perceber que
na verdade o hospital não era nem de
longe o ambiente de trabalho que eu
gostaria de atuar e eu também não gostei
de lidar com pessoas doentes
na verdade o que eu fiz foi aplicar o
mvp sem querer mas na verdade a gente
faz isso o tempo todo né
primeiro a gente antes de testar se a
gente quer realmente uma coisa pra
implementa a gente faz todos os passos
da insinuante de ver se aquilo realmente
vai dar certo a gente não testa antes a
gente não ver se aquilo realmente vai
funcionar
às vezes a gente assiste um pouco
difícil ou não sabe por onde começar e
aí vem a primeira dica que eu aprendi
para isso a gente precisa ser cara de
pau bater na porta do meu primeiro
estágio estava em dúvida se deveria
continuar na carreira técnica ou para
uma área mais gerencial e como eu fiz
isso eu fui cara de pau
eu peguei na empresa que trabalhava o
5150 gerentes que tinha conseguiu e meio
de todos eles envie um e mail para ele
pedindo para ter uma conversa com eles e
entender um pouco mais sobre a sua
escolha de carreira o que eles faziam o
dia a dia
nenhum deles me disse não eu conversei
com todos eles
isso me trouxe uma clareza gigantesca
para saber exatamente o que eu queria
fazer como próximo passo na minha
carreira o que me possibilitou que eu
fizesse que eu voltasse a carreira de
uma forma muito segura e aí o segundo
passo seria você não tá mvp e como é que
você começa a escolher um local para
testar suas habilidades não é mesmo
mas onde é que você quer trabalhar onde
que você pode colocar essas funções em
práticas e aí você é legal você começar
a forma mais fácil na sua rede de
contatos e seus familiares seus amigos
quem que tem alguma coisa que você possa
trabalhar que você possa colocar aquilo
que você quer em prática
e aí você faz isso mas aí você pensa bom
mas quem é que vai deixar trabalhar numa
empresa só para testar é muito simples
você vai até a empresa
você fala quais problemas que você pode
selecionar para ela e se oferece pra
resolver isso e fazer isso de graça
dificilmente alguém vai dizer que não
solucionar um problema e ainda de graça
o voluntariado é uma forma incrível e
você descobrir ainda as suas forças e
suas fraquezas em alguém seguro porque
você não tem muita cobrança em cima de
ti afinal não está recebendo dinheiro
por isso não tem um tempo e pode testar
o quanto é boa e pode desenvolver os
pontos fracos é um grande laboratório
você não percebe uma empresa para gerar
valor certo você pode gerar antes disso
na carreira é exatamente a mesma coisa
você não precisa se informar para
começar a exercer aquilo que você quer
você pode começar hoje
na verdade não pensei em começar uma
gradação pra começar a gerar algum valor
na sociedade ea gente na verdade a gente
faz muito ainda de empreendedorismo
convencional a gente tenta gerar
necessidades
encontrar nossa carreira mas a gente não
precisa fazer isso a gente pode sair do
nosso quarto sair da caixa e olhar os
problemas que estão ao nosso redor e ver
aquilo que mais incomoda o que a gente
mais reclama que quem demais não gosta a
gente pode começar a parar de reclamar
dessas coisas encontrar soluções
foi assim que comecei meu primeiro
negócio a minha mãe empreendia na moda
desde os 14 anos eu tinha certeza que
jamais trabalharia com moda a moda é
injusta a moda não é sustentável é a
quarta indústria mais poluidora do mundo
quase toda agrotóxico que do mundo a
maior parte está no algodão está na
roupa que a gente veste ela é injusta
com todo mundo que participa na cadeia
desde as costureiras designers as
modelos inclusive lojista só pra uma
pessoa satisfeita que o consumidor final
e às vezes nem isso acontece
e olha esse problema que tinha tão
grande na minha vida porque não sou
nacionais
e aí eu fundei uma empresa social de
moda que ela disse inclusive na parte
sustentável também na parte social e se
preocupa com todas as pessoas que
trabalham nessa cadeia
na verdade essa é a essência do
empreendedorismo e essa é a mais pura
mais fácil a gente encontrar nessa
cadeia em nossa carreira é solucionado
problemas e aí naturalmente a gente já
começa a fazer diferença
eu tenho preocupava muito com isso
depois de ter encontrado a minha
carreira não queria somente tem uma
carreira mas sim fazer algum impacto mas
como que a gente gera impacto como a
gente faz alguma diferença
como que a gente prende com o impacto
não tem jeito é através da liderança mas
o que a liderança na verdade a liderança
não é um conceito você não vai liberar
ninguém eu tenho um cargo na hierarquia
para exercer esse poder na sua vida o
que faz de um líder na verdade são as
suas habilidades dentre as habilidades
que ele pode ter o destaque é esse é o
pensamento global você não precisa se
preocupar só com você mas contudo que
tal redor orientado as soluções e não
problemas e proatividade autonomia e
auto conhecimento saber o que é o quê só
suas forças e quais são as suas
fraquezas saber transmitir o seu
conhecimento uma vez que pode adquiri
ele se tornar adaptável dessas
características a gente precisa de
algumas delas muito
foi muito intenso e empreendedorismo que
é a autonomia a proatividade e
adaptabilidade
vocês muitas vezes está sozinho e você
precisa tomar as decisões certas
você precisa ser a primeira da a dar o
primeiro passo e você precisa estar
pronto para se adaptar a vários
ambientes a mudar essa solução
compreendeu o que passa a volta ea gente
precisa disso também pra poder tomar as
decisões com muita consciência porque a
gente sempre tanto o empreendedorismo
quanto na carreira a gente recebe várias
dicas
todo mundo tá aí pra nos dar conselhos a
gente precisa saber quais desses
conselhos fazem sentido para nós na
nossa vida um concelho muito comum que a
gente ouve que houve várias vezes
enquanto fazia orientação vocacional é
siga seus interesses mas interesses em
vários né não sei vocês mas eu sempre
tive muito interesse a falta de
interesse nunca foi um problema para mim
mas sim abundância deles era muito
difícil escolher porque gostava de tudo
mas os seus interesses não são a base
para decidir qual carreira seguir
na mesmo eles mudam o tempo inteiro e
essa linha de a minha quarta de você não
pode apostar todos os ovos na mesma
cesta
você não pode investir tudo o que você
tem no seu projecto numa sua causa não
só propósito porque você pode ter vários
e talvez não seja mais importante que o
outro então comece fazendo várias coisas
até encontrar aquela que você mais gosta
que é o que mais fácil e melhor mas
talvez isso não acontecer não tem
problema você ter um propósito você pode
ter vários faça vários projetos e fique
com aqueles que vocês mais gostam
hoje eu faço mais cinco projetos de
hortas moda educação e até um carro de
corrida então se faz sentido pra você tá
tudo bem
na verdade nem sempre foi assim nem
sempre a gente falou para seguir suas
paixões essas esses conselhos eles vão
mudando com as décadas e com as gerações
na época dos nossos pais o conselho era
vá para o caminho mais fácil e mais
acessível é por isso que os nossos pais
tendem a seguir a profissão dos nossos
avós porque era mais fácil ele sabia
como chegar lá
o tempo foi mudando e os nossos irmãos
mais velhos eles decidiram
pelo mercado aquilo que tinha mais
dinheiro e para a via mais sucesso
sucesso era subir na carreira ser
promovido bem rápido e ganhar dinheiro
o tempo foi mudando na época que eu
nasci paixões e interesses era o que
importava de 1975 até os tempos de hoje
a frequência da frase se que a sua
paixão em refere como referências em
livros aumentou exponencialmente
muitas pessoas falam isso tem muitas
palestras sobre encontrar o seu
propósito da sua paixão mas recentemente
tem vários estudos sobre isso também
muitas das pessoas que encontraram seu
interesse trabalho no seu interesse e
ganha dinheiro com isso não estão
satisfeitos
não basta só gostar do que faz é preciso
um pouco mais que isso você precisa
gerar um impacto e aí vem a minha última
de você precisa moldar sua cadeira sua
carreira em torno de algo que
genuinamente ajude outras pessoas porque
aí você vai fazer o impacto e aí você
vai sentir preenchido com isso
esse é um exemplo de luta da equipe de
carro de corrida que eu sou membro que
eu entrei faz no início do ano e se eu
for pensar que propósitos existe nisso
eu estudar engenharia e eu sempre achei
que a engenharia é muito teórico não é
prática a gente tem muito poucos
projetos práticos na universidade e
ninguém dá a mínima pra eles
esse projeto é incrível nós fomos vice
campeões brasileiros no ano passado e
que nos possibilitou competir
mundialmente nos estados unidos neste
ano mas ninguém deu a mínima para isso
aí não tinha dinheiro pra lá porque a
universidade não investe nisso a
universidade não investe em teoria
prática e em coisas práticas só em
teoria
então entrei pra resolver esse problema
mas não sabia definitivamente como pôde
ajudar afinal isso de engenharia de
produção e engenharia mecânica
mas eu percebi que eles precisavam de
dinheiro para viajar e que isso era o
principal problema deles
eu fui pro marketing eu nunca tinha
trabalhado com marketing nem sabia fazer
nada disso mas eu fui pra lá porque
achei que lá eu poderia ajudar eu
descobri na verdade era fácil pra mim e
que eu gostava também de vender e
naturalmente eu comecei a sentir paixão
por aquilo
os resultados também vieram no final do
ano a gente conseguiu
a gente tem um patrocínio irá para o
mundial isso frame preencheu muito e
trouxe realmente sentido do que estava
fazendo
na verdade tudo o que a gente deve
começar é com o impacto que a gente quer
causar
resumindo as dicas que eu dei hoje você
primeiro começa com o impacto
depois você vê o que você gosta de fazer
o que é fácil que você vai sentir prazer
fazendo
e aí você aplica o mvp ver se realmente
dá certo para fazer isso as melhores
formas são batendo na porta e
voluntariado
existem várias idéias você pode gostar
de muitas coisas e se você não gostou
simplesmente bote da empresa mais
importante na sua vida você mesmo você é
o senhor da startup você e eu queria
deixar terminar essa
essa palestra com duas reflexões para
vocês
você é o dono das suas escolhas hoje
será que você está exercendo todo seu
potencial de liderança hoje obrigada